on this very fine day in our Republic I
am happy to report that the fine
conservatives of Wyoming have booted
America's leading Rhino Republican Liz
Cheney out of Congress Congress lady
Cheney was absolutely destroyed at The
Ballot Box yesterday losing her primary
race by
37.4 points which is a wonderful
beautiful absolutely delightful thing
some people might think that I'm being
too harsh on Liz Cheney here they will
say Liz Cheney look okay yeah she did
some stuff with the Dems but she was
right about a lot of things that's true
they'll say Liz Cheney voted with the
Republicans 90 even 95 percent of the
time that's true
that's true of all the squishes most of
the time the squishes seem like
conservatives that's what makes them
useful tools for the liberal
establishment Court gestures in the
Kingdom of liberalism most of the time
they seem like the real deal but no
matter how often these Court Jesters
vote with us at all the crucial moments
when the vote really counts when the
fight gets really hot they squish John
McCain voted with Republicans most of
the time he voted with Trump most of the
time and he absolutely hated Trump but
when McCain had the chance to cast the
deciding vote to repeal Obamacare a vote
that he had promised to make a central
plank of his campaign platform guess
what happened he squished he voted with
the Democrats same goes for Liz Cheney
she has voted with conservatives most of
the time
but at The crucial moments she squishes
at The crucial moment in 2020
she endorses Joe Biden
she flies cover for Nancy Pelosi's
Kangaroo Court hearings about January
6th
there's nothing Noble about it
the libs are trying to spin Cheney's
disloyalty as somehow Noble or dignified
there is nothing Noble about endorsing
Joe Biden there is nothing Noble about
supporting Pelosi's Kangaroo Court there
is nothing Noble about flying cover for
the party that Advocates killing babies
and transiting the kids and destroying
our country nothing Noble about that
some Republicans in moderate districts
sometimes feel that they have to squish
to save their seats and while I might
not agree with that I at least
understand the political calculus
but Liz Cheney she represents Wyoming
soon to say represented Wyoming
she doesn't need to swish on anything
the only pressure that she feels to
squish comes from her deranged hatred of
Donald Trump
and of his supporters and her wounded
pride and the popular opinions of the DC
swamp which apparently had much more
sway with her than the desires of her
constituents in Wyoming
let Cheney's undignified and unnecessary
loss be a lesson let it underscore a
lesson
that I try to reiterate on this show as
often as I can
never
ever
squish to the libs
right now head on over to
goodranchers.com Michael our friends
over at good ranchers are on a mission
to donate 100
000 high quality meals this month to
children in need to help them Reach
their goal 10 lucky listeners who
purchase a box of my absolute favorite
meat delicious American meat from
goodranchers.com Michael will win a
30-minute Zoom call experience with me
on September 30th you know what we're
calling it we're calling it a meet and
greet do you get it you better you
better hurry up and sign up right now
this offer is only valid through August
31st buy from goodranchers.com Michael
save 30 on your box of 100 American Meat
plus free shipping and be entered to win
a 30-minute Zoom session with me off the
clock Let's help these guys reach their
goal of one hundred thousand donated
meals this month and then you and I can
hang out in a meet and greet and maybe
who knows maybe I'll be eating good
ranchers during the meet and greet I'm
not sure all I know is I eat good
ranchers pretty much three times a week
I absolutely adore their meats you will
too head on over goodranchors.com
Michael not to put too fine a point on
it I will move on from spiking the
football over the Liz Cheney loss but
there's one point I've really gotta hit
here because you're gonna hear it from
the libs all day who have a strange new
respect for Liz Cheney who are almost
certainly going to offer her a job on
The View it's kind of sad for that lady
Alyssa Farah Alyssa Farah is the new
fake Republican on The View she's the
new fake conservative and she just got
the job but now Liz Cheney who is the
darling fake conservative she's
certainly gonna get the job offer within
what five minutes 10 minutes now that
she's lost I guess she has to leave
Congress officially first that won't
happen until January but if I were a
less affera if I were any of the other
fake conservatives on CNN or MSNBC I'd
be looking over my shoulder
because you've got I don't know how much
job security you've got with Liz Cheney
back on the market but with this with
the libs and what even many of the
squishy Republicans are going to say is
you know
you might not agree with Liz Cheney but
she showed dignity she showed
independence of thought she is her own
man or in this her own woman in this
case that's what they're going to say
and what's so Insidious about this
argument is that
in principle that would be a great thing
in principle we don't just want to be
partisan hacks this is actually a really
important point in in Dante's Divine
Comedy my favorite poem Dante you know
everyone knows about Dante's inferorno
the hell part of it which is very
interesting and titillating but then he
goes to purgatory and then he goes up to
heaven and when Dante gets up to heaven
he meets his most illustrious ancestor
kachiguita kachiguide was this Crusader
it's the man from whom Dante gets his
family name and so kachiguit is giving
Dante political advice and Dante was a
politician too in addition to a poet and
he says listen Dante politics is going
to be really bad for you you're going to
get stabbed in the back your opponents
even the people you're with they're
going to go crazy it's going to give you
all sorts of problems and he's
foreshadowing Dante's political Exile
from Florence and he says it's really
really bad
and he says don't worry about those
people the people who are giving you all
this grief in politics they're going to
go to hell okay but if you want to
protect your honor if you want to
protect yourself the best way to do it
is to be a party of yourself
I love the Italian that sounds so
beautiful
how beautiful that is and not only is
the language beautiful the the idea is
beautiful too
you don't want to just be some hack
Republican or some hack Democrat you can
Ally with these people you know politics
is a team sport you've got to work with
people to get things done but you you
want to be your own man absolutely
that's not what Liz Cheney did that's
not what she did
it may have it would even if she had
done that it still would have been dumb
because of the content of what she was
doing she was turning on Trump for a
bunch of stupid reasons and she was
giving up all the wonderful wonderful
political wins because of her own
wounded Pride
and her own kind of swampiness but at
least it would be more understandable
even maybe more honorable
than what she actually did she wasn't a
party of herself she wasn't a Maverick
she wasn't a rogue she wasn't her own
person she just for all intents and
purposes became a Democrat she endorsed
Joe Biden
she voted for a guy
who accepted a taxpayer taxpayer-funded
abortion on demand who's advocating
transiting little kids who is wants to
throw open the borders and has thrown
open the national borders of the United
States
to say nothing of his horrible economic
policies stupid foreign policy
she sided with him
she became the front man for Nancy
Pelosi's kangaroo court
she's not she is not some independent
thinker no she just stabbed her former
allies in the back
for very bad reasons and now she's out
of Congress or soon we'll be out of
Congress
and that is a wonderful thing
on the substance even Beyond her own
behavior in the process and the ways in
which he conducted herself on the
substance she was wrong
Bill Crystal the you know former editor
of the Weekly Standard former
conservative
makatimak who's now I guess a kind of
liberal
critic and gadfly of the Trump
conservatives
he said in 2016 he said between the Deep
State and the Trump State I choose the
Deep State and he has reiterated that
point since then
Liz Cheney
essentially made the same argument
and
I'll speak for myself I assume I'm
speaking for you here between the Deep
State and the Trump State I choose the
Trump State meaning I choose the old
American way of life the traditional
American order the will of the American
people over a bunch of unaccountable
unelected bureaucrats who are extremely
corrupt and left wing
and every every single time you see a
showdown between the Trump State and the
Deep State the Deep State comes out
looking even more corrupt and Trump
comes out looking even better
no matter what the media tried to say
you're seeing this again now CBS just
got caught in a big lie flacking for the
Deep State and unfairly attacking Trump
Nora O'Donnell on CBS after Donald Trump
came out and said hey the doj not the
FBI not only did they go through
melania's closet not only did they take
a bunch of my documents not only do they
raid my house an unprecedented way they
took my passports
Nora O'Donnell says new according to a
doj official the FBI is not in
possession of former president Trump's
passports Trump had accused the FBI of
stealing his three passports during the
surge on his Mar-A-Lago home
I just talked to the doj and they told
me they totally didn't do that
and then here's the second tweet when
she realized she probably got it wrong
she goes we're also learning tonight
that if any items not contained in the
warrant were retrieved during the FBI
surge at Mar-A-Lago they will be
returned
yeah he didn't do that they didn't take
any of that stuff but they'll give it
back
and then Trump just publishes an email
from the doj acknowledging
that yeah they did take his passports
and what does CBS do what does Nora
O'Donnell do there it is
we've learned that the filter agencies
three passports belonging to president
Trump oopsie Daisy we'll give them back
soon sorry what does CBS do no deletion
no correction no apology moving on
moving on you've got the evidence of the
corruption of the abuse of the deceit of
the deep State and the media
propagandists for them right in front of
you what do they do nope never mind darn
that that Roadrunner Trump got away from
us Wiley coyotes again all right that's
okay we'll get him next time never mind
get me the next Acme Anvil how do we get
him again
and Liz Cheney and the rest of the
squishes they side with them
pathetic
I'm so glad you liked that clip be sure
now to subscribe get the notifications
ring the bell right now you can do it we
got 1 million subscribers now it's time
to get a billion
ring the bell we'll see you next time
foreign
[Music]